Hello everyone. I have just a very quick
DIY video. In this DIY video, I'm going
to show you how to reprogram a key. Some
keys you'll have um any of these diamond
keys for BMW E39, E46 will actually lose
its connection to the car. So, you'll
press the unlock button. If I press it,
mine still works, but some of them
aren't working. So, in this video, I'm
just going to actually show you how to
reprogram this key. key if you already
have an existing key that's working on
the car. I'm going to show you how to
program the key. And I think this also
works for new keys that have the same um
the actual key pattern with this. I
think this will work for to actually
link it up to the car to unlock and
lock. It will not start the car if if
this key hasn't previously started the
car. Like this car will start the car
cuz of the other chip in it, but it will
it um it just doesn't unlock and lock
the car. So, I'll show you in this video
exactly what is needed to do that. All
you need is your key. And to start off,
get in your car, make sure both your
doors are closed. I have just a coupe,
so there's only two doors, but if you
have a four-door car, make sure all four
doors are closed, and then proceed with
this. Make sure they're not open because
it will not work and it will not put it
into the reprogramming mode or pairing
mode for the car. So, I'll be back in
the next clip to show you exactly how to
start doing this. So, to start off,
again, I'm just going to make sure to
tell you guys to make sure your doors
are closed, and what you're going to do
is you're going to take your key, put it
into I'll demonstrate in a second, but
you're going to put it into the key
slot, turn it one, click to position
one, and turn it back off, and pull it
with remove it within 5 seconds. So,
basically, you're going to go like this.
You're going to take it in,
take it right out. I'll do that again
for you. So, I basically went
in, click, one, click, back out. And
basically to tell that you're in
position one, I'll show you how to tell
if you're position one. So, if I put the
key in and if I go like that, that's
position one where just the service um
this the oil light lights up with your
mileage and the radio is on like that.
No AC controls, no dash clusters. This
is position two. As you can see, all my
lights come on. This is what we we don't
want. We just want it to look like this.
So that's position one. So again, you're
going to take the key,
put it in, one click, take it back out
within 5 seconds. And now I will show
you the next part of what you actually
have to do. I'm going to try to show you
in my lap of what you have to do. And
I'll be back with that. So one thing I
for forgot to actually mention in the
beginning of this video, when you start,
make sure that your door your car doors
are both shut. All four of them or two
of them if you have a coupe. And also
make sure your w your doors are
unlocked. So to do this now, you're what
you're gonna do is you're gonna hold the
unlock button and then press the BMW
button. You're gonna press it. You're
gonna go hold it and press the BMW
button three times with about two second
break in between. So I'll show you how
I'm going to do that right now. So, I'm
going to hold down the the lock button,
and I'm going to go one,
two,
three, and your doors
should cycle the lock just like they
did. And now you're done. And you can
reprogram as many keys as you want. But
one thing that I like to do after, you
don't have to do this, just reinsert the
key back into um the car. I mean, I
don't know if it's necessary. You're
just going to reinsert it back into
position one again.
One 5 seconds within 5 seconds and pull
it back off just like I just did. Um,
it's a pretty basic DIY. It might take
you a couple times to actually do the
part where you have to um
do the hold down the buttons where you
have to hold down the unlock button and
then while holding the unlock button you
have to press the uh the BMW button
three times. You have to go one, two,
three. That might take you a couple
times and you might and you have to do
that within 30 seconds of a actually
pulling out the key. So, I mean, just do
it in one sequence. It's enough time for
you to do it. It's really not that
difficult, but again, it might take you
a couple times. If you just follow my
instructions, you'll be all set and you
will be able to reprogram a a key that
does not work and make it working. Um,
that's it for this DIY. It's a very
short DIY, very easy. If you think your
batteries may be dead, try repairing it
first. And it might take you a couple
times to repair it, but odds are that
will fix the issue because when you
actually put this key into the ignition
like this, when I put it into the
ignition, it's charging the battery in
the key, which is a really cool concept
for BMW. It's charging the battery in
the key right now, just having it in the
ignition. So maybe you're it just lost
the pair, the signal that's used for,
and you can try this. This works on any
of these diamond shaped keys for any of
the BMW E46s, E39, E um
and E53.
I don't know if it's anything else, but
I know those ones are it. But thank you
guys so much for watching. Don't forget
to like, comment, subscribe. I look
forward to seeing you guys in the next
video.